Alright, we're back, what's the answer Michael?
>> So, you want me to work it through?
>> Sure.
>> So what I did first is I made it to, I extended the table that you had.
>> Okay.
>> To include each of these, the output for each of
these three functions. What I'm basically, what I like to do is
compute the squared error for each of these three functions on that
data and then choose the one that has the lowest squared error.
>> Make total sense to me. Sounds good
enough to be an algorithm. So you want me
to write out the table?
>> Well, I mean, I started to do that, and then there
was like one too many steps, and I just threw out my
hand and just wrote a program. Okay, so, we'll just say"
Insert code here", because that's what you did, that was the step.
>> And, what did your code tell you?
>> Well, let me start with the constant function, because that's the
easiest piece of code. So, I'm saying what's the difference between each
of the D values and two. Squaring it all and summing it
up and I get 19. And I can do the same thing,
instead of using two I use x over three take the difference of that
to the D values and square that and I get 19 point four, four, four,
four, four, four. Then I can do, right, so now at this point I'm
rock and rolling. I can actually just substitute in my nine, and I get 12?
>> Not, not something-odd 12?
>> No, just 12, so the error's 12. So that has the smallest error.
So even though that's sort of a crazy, like, stripy function
right. Like, it increases linearly and then it resets at 9.
>> Mmhmm.
>> It actually fits the state of the best.
>> That is correct. Your code is correct, Michael. Well done. Well actually,
looking at this data that sort of makes sense to me, right. Because
if you look at the first three examples. Of the data, the outputs
are very close. But the outputs of the next three are much bigger, and
by doing a mod nine, what you effectively do is
say, this is the identity function above this line. And then
below the line, it's as if I'm sort of subtracting
nine from all of them, and that makes them closer together.
>> Hm.
>> And so it just happens to work out
here. But surely that's just because we came up
with a bad constant function and a bad linear
function. Do you think there's a better linear function?
>> So I mean because it's the squared
error, we're really just talking about linear regression.
>> Right.
>> So I can just run linear regression. So I get
an intercept of 0.9588 And a, and a slope of 0.1647.
>> Okay
>> So that's, so that's my linear function of choice.
>> Okay, so that's, what was, what was that again?
>> So x times, you know, it's like a six, I guess, like 0.165 probably.
>> 0.165x
>> Plus
>> Mm hm.
>> Plus 0.959. So that's
our function, that's our best linear function,
the function that minimizes greater. So it better
end up being, it better end up being less than 19.4, or I'm a liar.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And now I need to take the difference
between that and D square it, and sum. 15.7.
>> Hm. So that gives you 15, I'm going to say 15.8. So that is better.
>> Yeah, so it's better than the X over three,
but it's also worse than the mod nie.
>> Hm.
>> and the best constant function, has to be worse, because the linear
functions include the constant functions as a subset, so this is, that 15.8 is.
Is better than the best constant function too. Oh its easy to do
though right? Because the best constant function is just the mean of the data.
>> What is the mean of the data?
>> 2.17.
>> huh two is pretty close.
>> Yeah that's interesting.
>> Well that's
>> Kind of in the middle of the pack
I guess.
>> That sort of works right because two the error
for two was actually lower than the error for x divided
by three. And for what it's worth the error for
2.17 as constant function to 2.2 is 8.8, 18.8, 18.8 sorry.
>> Yeah, you're not the [INAUDIBLE].
>> Yeah, eight would have been less than everything.
>> Okay. So, what have we learned here?
>> That sometimes you want to use mod.
>> Yeah.
>> If your data is weird. [LAUGH]
>> You have you
have definitely modified my box.
>> Well I'm glad you found it mod. Hmm. [LAUGH]
PUNS. Okay, good, so I think that was
a good, that was, that was a good exercise.
So I'm going to give you one more example
of deriving something and then we're going to move on.
>> Cool.
>> Okay.